Do you think this video will be
on the Internet in 2070?
Maybe in some... Internet archive
somewhere?
Well, researchers of the future
if you were wondering what
we were doing
here in the 2020s about
climate change
the answer is we were committing
to net zero.
In the past few years
more than 70 countries,
one after the next...
have made a pledge to reach
net zero emissions.
That includes places that have barely
contributed to climate warming...
and it includes all of the countries
that have been most responsible
for emissions so far.
It seems like everyone
got the message
that humankind needs to become
carbon neutral
and we need to do it
in the next 3 to 5 decades.
But that would have been easier
if we had started cutting emissions
20 years ago
because now we're up here
and the math is getting
really tough.
So to make it work
governments are penciling in
"negative emissions."
That's the net part of the
net zero promise.
The idea that we can reach zero
while still emitting greenhouse gases
if we're also taking CO2
out of the air.
It's a bit contentious
but we're going to be hearing
a lot about it.
-It's called CDR.
-CDR.
So carbon dioxide removal.
What we want to do is put that carbon
back where it belongs.
Giana Amador is
a CDR advocate
and she's going to help us explain this
with the bathtub metaphor.
The bathtub in this situation
is our atmosphere
and the water in the bathtub
is the CO2
that's in our atmosphere.
Before the Industrial Revolution
the land and ocean typically released
as much CO2 into the air
as they absorbed back down
through this drain.
But when people started
digging up coal and oil
to power their machines, first in Europe
and then in the US
it sent this new flow of CO2
into the air
one that the plants and oceans
couldn't keep up with.
About 45% of those emissions
stay in the atmosphere
trapping heat and setting us up
for an escalating array of
climate disasters.
So in 2015, all of the countries
send someone off to Paris
to say, “Okay, everyone, we need
to keep warming
well below two degrees Celsius.”
And really we're aiming
for 1.5 degrees.
That's above pre-industrial levels.
And the exact numbers matter
less than the fact that
every increment of warming
increases risk.
So first and foremost,
we need to turn off the tap.
Everything else is futile
if we don't stop the root
of the problem today.
Turn off that tap.
Stop emitting CO2.
Not only have we not
turned off any taps.
Global emissions are still rising,
especially in Asia...
where, you know, 60%
of human beings live
many of whom are just emerging
out of poverty.
So now we're here at nearly
1.2 degrees of warming.
Frankly, we have not done
what it would take
to meet that 1.5 degree goal.
But we may be able to keep
warming under two degrees
if all of those net zero promises
become real net zero policies.
And that's where things
get a little tricky.
Turning these emissions all the way off
could get really hard
really expensive or even unfair.
So everyone's kind of hoping
that we can work from the
bottom of the tub
to... kind of increase the size of the drain
increase the speed at which we can drain
that water from the bathtub.
Now, CDR is distinct
from CCS
which prevents emissions at the source.
That works on the faucet.
CDR grabs CO2 from the air
and people have come up with a lot of
interesting ways of doing that.
The most common one so far is
planting and protecting forests.
It's one of the more affordable
CDR approaches right now
and it has a lot of benefits
aside from capturing CO2.
But we've seen from problems
with the carbon offsets market
that it can be hard to verify.
And, you know, trees
don't live forever.
So most of the modeling scenarios
that limit warming
assume we’ll also be able
to build a new drain
for more permanent
carbon storage.
So through things like rock weathering,
we can crush up a bunch of rocks
that naturally react with CO2 and
try to speed up that reaction.
Or we can use chemistry
to mimic...
natural processes through technologies
like direct air capture
which basically use a type of chemical
that selectively binds
with CO2 to capture it
from the air.
These techniques all come
with different costs
and they're in really early stages
of development.
So there's a concern that the
people in charge of the faucets
will see any movement
down here as an excuse
to avoid making cuts
up there.
Should we be counting on
large amounts of carbon removal
for our climate plans?
Well, it seems we already are.
The US government's net zero plan
calls for 500 million metric tons
of CO2 removal
by 2050, up from
zero today.
Model simulations
that limit warming to 1.5 degrees
envision around 3.8 billion tons
of permanent
carbon removal globally every year.
And this...
is the total amount of permanent
carbon removal
that has happened so far.
So would you call that
wishful thinking?
Or is it foresight about how much
can happen in 30 years
if we start our way up
the learning curve now?
We have actually a really
strong playbook
of developing technologies and
driving down costs.
If we go all the way
back to the 1970s
we see technologies like solar PV
be around $70 per watt.
Fast forward to 2023.
We see those prices down
at around $0.07 per watt
or even lower and at price parity
with fossil fuels.
The challenge with that
is that renewable energy produces
something that's quite useful,
which is energy and CDR...
What is the customer for CDR?
Where does the demand
come from?
You've seen some major companies
including Stripe, Meta, Alphabet,
McKinsey, Microsoft...
All of these companies
have made commitments
to purchase carbon dioxide removal
as part of their
corporate social responsibility plans.
That being said, I think
in the long term
carbon removal could be provided
as a public service
in the ways that that we manage
some of our other pollution.
We pay for someone to come around
to collect our trash
and to manage it in a way that
it's safe for our communities.
The US government is already
offering billions of dollars
to try to get a direct air capture industry
off the ground.
And I think it makes sense for the countries
that have used the most fossil fuels
to do the work of finding out
if CDR can scale.
But if it doesn't...
well, then net zero will have been
just another way
of kicking the can down the road.
Which, of course, is how we ended up
here in the first place.
In this position where we may now
have no choice...
but to try everything.